Welcome back everyone it's Charlie this is
going to be my new mandalorian season 2 video
all about the mandalorian jedi of the past
and currently on the show force sensitive
mandalorians i'm doing videos for all the episodes
this season so if you're brand new to the channel
be sure to subscribe to get those we're doing a
giveaway for disney plus memberships all you have
to do to enter is be a subscriber and let me
know when do you think that the mandalorian is
actually going to get his hands on the darksaber
so blanket spoiler warning for everything that's
happened on the mandalorian so far in season one
and season two but starting at the beginning here
there's only actually ever been one member of
the mandalorian clans the mandalorian people who
formally became a jedi in the traditional sense
the important thing to remember too is that just
because you're force sensitive and you're badass
with the lightsaber doesn't mean that you're a
jedi you actually have to be a member of the order
inducted and consider yourself a jedi a member of
the order to be called one that's why even though
ahsoka is very powerful and she was trained as a
jedi but she is not a jedi herself but the only
mandalorian who ever formally became a jedi was
named tarre vizsla and he was just a male born
to house vizsla which is one of their powerful
families on mandalore the homeworld thousands of
years ago remember the mandalorian jedi wars that
they talk about on the show he was born during
a period when they currently were not at war
there was no one single war it was just a
series of many wars and conflicts going back
thousands and thousands of years to the dawn of
the jedi and the old republic the old republic
era is basically anywhere from a thousand years
to 25,000 years ago in galactic history so it
covers an enormous period of history tarr vizsla
was born closer to the end of the old republic era
but because they weren't at war the jedi sensed
that he was force sensitive and thought that he
might be a bridge between their peoples and help
bring about peace between the mandalorians in the
old republic so as was the custom they took him
as a child and brought him to the jedi temple
he became a jedi and as was the mandalorian custom
sought to distinguish himself from the other
jedi fashioning a unique lightsaber that was
called the darksaber later he returned to the
mandalorian people as an adult became mandalore
the great one of the mandalore the greats the one
that they speak of during the mandalorian season
one and it did lead to an era of peace between the
mandalorians and the jedi while he was alive
there's a lot of legends canon that goes back
even further in the old republic era that talk
about other mandalorians that were referred to as
mandalore the great so mandalore is really just
a title that's given to whoever's leading the
entirety of the mandalorian people at any given
time so for instance right now on the tv show in
the mandalorian season two there is no mandalore
because the clans aren't united they're all hidden
in different coverts different pockets all over
the outer rim territories they've been scattered
i think part of their arc on the series is that
eventually the clans will reunite and they'll
retake their homeworld or they'll find a new
home world to live on then you would name a new
mandalore but also during mandalorians history
there were the jedi crusaders they were a group
of mandalorians during the mandalorian jedi wars
over the years that were trained in jedi fighting
techniques counter jedi fighting techniques and
given special best guard steel swords to fight
them with if you're talking about hand-to-hand
combat jedi training martial arts make all the
terracotta references you want there actually is
a new star wars disney plus spin-off series that's
going to be martial arts based so we'll see if
they have easter eggs for that during that show
but the whole reason why they would fight jedi
with best guard steel swords is because they're
resistant to lightsabers in fact that's the whole
reason their armor was made from bescar steel
originally that didn't use to be the case back
before they fought the jedi many many thousands
of years ago their armor still looked like that
but it was made from more common materials still
very strong but during the very first mandalorian
jedi wars the jedi cut through them like butter
their forces were almost obliterated instantly
that inspired them to devise countermeasures to
the jedi weapons and thus best scar steel was
created they also devised hunting and fighting
tactics to match the jedi and the mandalorian
crusaders were born the jedi hunters so to speak
but sometimes they also teamed up with the
jedi if you remember eulec kael droma from
the tales of the jedi comics way way back he
fought eksarkoon one of the old republic-born
human sith lords there's newer canonical versions
of his history where he commanded a squad of
mandalorian jedi crusaders during an operation
so sometimes they did work with the jedi but
because there have been billions and billions of
mandalorians you would think that there would be
many of them that would have been force sensitive
over the thousands and thousands of years of their
culture's history the main reason why you've only
heard about tarre vizsla being the only one to be
trained as a jedi is mostly because of all the
wars that they had with the old republic and the
jedi themselves just their relationship with them
so yes there have been many mandalorians who were
born force sensitive but just never received any
training or developed their abilities but the very
final mandalorian jedi war happened long after
tarvisla had died with his death relations between
the mandalorians and the old republic got worse
and eventually unrelated to that the old republic
basically collapsed through a lot of infighting
and civil wars and out of the ashes of that
the republic was born the thing that died when the
empire was born so you have the old republic then
the republic then the empire then the new republic
but while the old republic was metaphorically in
the process of dying members of house vizsla at
the time about a thousand years ago snuck into
the jedi temple on coruscant stole back tarre
vizsla's dark saber and used it as a symbol to
unite the mandalorians for several hundred more
years many many generations of their family until
eventually it wound up in the hands of pre-vizsla
john favreau's character on the clone wars series
he was also the leader of the death watch
mandalorians the people that rescued din jaren
on the mandalorian season one in that flashback
scene deathwatch themselves were pretty big groups
so we don't know if pre vizsla's character was
actually here while this was happening at the time
but house vizsla the people that were passing the
darksaber down through generations of their family
is meant to be a separate group from the death
watch mandalorians for instance the mandalorian
heavy infantryman that john favreau also played
during the mandalorian season 1 was named
paz vizsla so he was just another member
of house vizsla too but he didn't have the
death watch markings on his armor so he wasn't
a member of death watch but bringing this back
around to mandalorian children also for those of
you asking about force sensitive children that
just happen to be rescued by the mandalorians
who themselves then become mandalorians by
creed like denjarin not born to mandalorian
families but becoming mandalorian by choice
there have also been many force-sensitive children
over the many thousands of years of their people
taken from other cultures who were inducted as
mandalorians but never formally trained as jedi
one of the other best examples of this is
baby yoda or the child whatever you want
to call him himself he's basically a member of
the mandalorians clan which kind of makes him a
mandalorian by creed even though he himself hasn't
spoken or taken the oath that dinjaran took when
he became a mandalorian it's just an example of
a force-sensitive child who's taken in by the
mandalorians and becomes a mandalorian themselves
so i know a lot of you are now asking about moff
gideon in dinjarin being force sensitive on the
show there was something that giancarlo esposito
said that made people wonder if moff gideon
might be force sensitive or may have even been
a mandalorian at one time but was left or cast
out like jango fett you have to remember that mob
gideon would have had a traditional education
in the imperial academy so he would have been
a teenager during the clone wars when this is
happening and din djarin is being rescued he's
probably about 15 years older than the mandalorian
so he probably would have been a junior cadet
during the clone wars but giancarlo esposito said
that moff gideon at least on the show right now
himself has a reverence for the force in the ways
of the jedi he's very learned and studied in the
force in the ways of the jedi his job before he
became a moth was in the imperial security bureau
was information gathering so he spent all this
time studying and collecting artifacts kind of
like emperor palpatine hoarding things that would
have inevitably led him to the darksaber he was
stationed near the mandalorian sector during
the great purge that would have given him the
perfect opportunity to pilfer any mandalorian
artifacts that he wanted including taking the
darksaber from katie sackoff's bo katan who was
the leader of the mandalorian people at the time
and it's through his study of the force that
he's devised his quote-unquote grand plan for
reunifying the galaxy under a new empire which
involves his plans for baby yoda the child as he
calls it the darksaber is just one of his prized
possessions because of what it represents in its
symbolic power but really baby yoda is his
prized possession we haven't seen much from
him early on the show but there are a couple
really big surprises from his character that
are going to be really cool in the next couple of
episodes also when you talk about the mandalorian
dinjarin and the force himself you have to think
about his character arc on the show he goes from
being this cynical jaded bounty hunter killer for
hire mercenary type who then becomes a believer
over time so to speak because of the influence of
the child on him baby yoda inspires him to believe
in things like the force the jedi quote-unquote
enemy sorcerers as he calls them like he used
to hate droids because the battle droids killed
his parents but then ig-11 wins his respect and
he stops hating all droids they made a joke about
that during episode two is the same thing with his
belief in the force in the jedi it's just that
as of me posting this video he hasn't run into
other former jedi like ahsoka yet but the way
they're setting this up though through his story
arc is that he would become a true believer so
to speak eventually and i think by that time by
the end of his arc he himself will wield the
darksaber but just in terms of how they're
pacing the series and that story out if john
carlo esposito did that live stream before the
season started saying that it'd be season 4 before
we got all the answers about what this all means
and all the teasers that they've laid down then
i don't think that he's going to be able to take
the dark saber permanently from moff gideon until
the final season of the show whichever season that
winds up being they haven't said how long it's
going to run so lay your theories about that but
what will happen next is is my full mandalorian
season 2 episode 3 video will post friday just
like normal leave all your video requests on the
comments below there's a couple big mandalorian
videos that i'm working on that i'm waiting to
post till a little bit later there's still a
lot of really really big stuff they're going to
be introducing ahsoka is just one of the biggest
things that they're bringing onto season two will
you wait for everything click here for my full
mandalorian season 2 episode 2 video and click
here to learn what's going on with luke skywalker
during the mandalorian season 2. thank you so much
for watching everyone stay safe this is the way!